and it's the same deal with b which
watch what happens when i um alter this
you can see that this changes the scale
of things if you want to talk about it
this way
it moves the hyperbola further away from
the origin
but no matter how far you go away you're
still going to have you can see it right
there
you're still going to have these points
of intersection they'll just be at
different
locations right so the feature
of the sketch that indicates that there
are two square roots is that there are
always
two points of intersection between
these two equations here so when you're
solving simultaneously you'll always
find two solutions
that means there will always be two
square roots to any complex number
so then it says part a investigate how
the sketch changes when either
a or b or both are negative
or zero so let's uh let's take those one
at a time let's have a look at the
negative case
first so let's bring these back into
something a bit closer to what we
started with
all right let's see what happens when we
change a to be negative right now it's
1.4
watch what happens as i shift it over to
a
negative value oopsie daisy it's quite
cool to watch
here's me making a smaller and smaller
you can see
those two those two points there on the
bottom
kind of we call them the vertices of the
hyperbola the bits that are bent in
and the middle they're kind of getting
closer and closer together right as i
get closer to zero
they actually collide we'll come back to
this case later
and then whoa what just happened
uh let's go back to the positive this is
what the hyperbola looks like before
you can see it has like a left and a
right hand half but then when i
cross over a becomes negative you don't
have a left and a right half to your
hyperbola
you now have a top and a bottom and what
i'm going to do is i'm just going to let
this animate you can see it changing
which is quite
satisfying to watch so when a is
negative
the key question is what happens to our
solution with the red graph our points
of intersection i should say
well you still always get the two points
of intersection you can see there
it's highlighted by desmos with those
gray circles don't look at the
intercepts
look at the points of intersection with
the red graph no matter where your green
graph goes even when you've got a
negative value
you still have that pair of solutions
let me hit pause
on on that guy there let's bring that
now to the middle
let's have a look at zero so what
happens when a equals
zero well a if you recall a is the real
component
of the complex number that we started
with a plus ib
so what this is saying is what if you
don't have a real component what if you
have a purely
imaginary number well what that tells us
is when you have a look at these
solutions
the real and imaginary part of your two
solutions there you can see
they're equal in magnitude right so
this makes sense because if you've got
complex numbers that are equal in
magnitude like this
when you multiply them together the the
argument to say
um 1.285 plus 1.285
i um the argument to that will be pi on
4. you can see i'm counting it
i'm measuring up from the positive real
axis so pi on 4
when you multiply that number by itself
the pi on 4
multiplied by itself adds part 4 again
you can see it's on the
real sorry the purely imaginary axis
there the positive imaginary axis in
that case
and the same thing happens for the other
solution that you've got the other
square root this guy here
i'll get rid of that one minus 1.285
minus 1.285 i what is its
principal argument well it's going to be
not pi on 4
but negative 3 pi on 4. and when you go
from the positive real axis you go
negative 3 pi 4
if you go another negative 3 pi and 4
that's the same as negative 3 pi on 2
which is the same as pi on 2. so again
you're back on the real
axis sorry the purely imaginary axis i
keep on
getting that wrong so this is really
delightful to me right that in order to
get
a square root
of a purely imaginary number like that
then you're going to have its complex
square roots being either here you know
it's got a
an argument of pi on 4 here so pi on 4
pi on 4 again
brings you up to pi on 2 or you could be
on the uh
the other side and you're going to go
minus 3 pi on 4
then minus 3 pi on 4 again which is
minus 3.2 in total which is the same as
pi on 2 in the principal argument
so let's come back to our graph that's
what happens when a equals 0 and we've
already investigated what happens when a
is is negative now let's think about b
right
so here is the hyperbola it's changing
it's going sort of in and out it's like
breathing now what happens when b
becomes negative watch carefully where
the hyperbola goes
it crosses over just like the other
hyperbola right which shouldn't be
surprising because these are both
hyperbolas just in a different
orientation when you go to b
being negative you have answers in the
opposite quadrant so
uh you know when b is positive you're
getting solutions in the first and third
quadrants
when b is negative you're getting them
in the second and fourth
quadrants which brings us back to
something really important that we
looked at earlier when we were first
looking at
square roots and getting them in
rectangular form or in exponential form
i'm doing an exponential form is really
nice and neat because you arrive
at this result down here it's just plus
or minus this
one of the things we didn't notice
though is it's quite sneaky right
is that in its current form the two
solutions that i have for this
particular like this is the particular
complex number we're having looking for
defined square roots
when you have a look at these two
solutions i haven't written them
properly in exponential form
what do i mean by that well there's a
negative case in a positive case here
right
plus or minus that's what it means so
you've got minus 2
e to the i pi on 3 and then you've got
the positive case 2 e
i to the uh sorry to the i pi on 3. now
this complex number over here this
square root this has no problems this is
already written nicely in exponential
form because you've got
2 being the modulus and then pi on 3
being the argument so
this all looks good it matches what we
want this is in r
e to the i theta but when you have a
look over this
this is actually not written in the
right form right because
even though you have an argument over
here it actually doesn't make sense
because that's not where this complex
number is it is not found
by rotating pi on 3 radians from the
positive real axis
in the anticlockwise direction nor is
the modulus negative 2 because
the modulus can't be negative it's a
distance after all so in fact in order
to
get what this actual number is we have
to think about where it is
and then correct the modulus make it
positive
and then therefore get the appropriate
argument how do we do that
well the easiest way to think about it
is there is a relationship between
a complex number and what happens when
you just slap a minus sign on the front
right if we think about this in
rectangular form you can see how this is
all
interconnected if you think about some
random complex number and what happens
when you slap a minus sign
on the front what's that equal to it's
minus
a minus i b so it's in the opposite
quadrant
right this is what we're looking at on
the graph here you can see
here's um here's one solution this one
happens to be in the second
quadrant and here is its opposite in the
fourth quadrant right so you can see in
order to uh
you know convert that properly i'm going
to have to say well
if if this one here i know where that is
it's in the first quadrant so let me
just quickly draw it it's going to look
like this
oops i'm going to go pi on 3 radians
like that and then that is my modulus of
2 so this is 2
e to the i pi on three whereas it's
opposite well if i go
down in this direction this would be
minus two e to the i pi on three
but noting the symmetry here if this is
pi on three radians that means
this guy here is pion3 radians which
means that
coming from the opposite direction this
must be negative 2
pi on 3 radians because they're
supplementary angles
what that tells me is that the modulus
is still 2
but the correct argument the principal
argument
in this case is actually 2 e to the i
negative 2 pi on 3 right so
what i'm trying to get across here is i
have this relationship which is
on opposite sides between my two
solutions and that's what you can see
by varying the value of b you're always
going to be on those opposite sides
because the two branches of the
hyperbola are always in opposite
quadrants the last thing is when you
have a look at b equals zero let's have
a look at that
right there whoops i got my fingers are
too stubby
i'll get it psychos
i wonder if i can just type there we go
that's better so b equals zero i've just
forced it there right
what does this mean well if b equals
zero coming back to our original
question what that means is when you
have a look at this arbitrary complex
number
there is no imaginary part um
a plus i times zero it's just an a right
so now what we're thinking of is not the
square root of complex number
we're thinking of the square root of a
real number
and not just the principle square root
we're thinking about both
square roots so now if we come back over
to our graph
if i pick a value of a that's uh nice
something like say
9 okay i've learned
just type it there so in this case if
i've got
a equal to nine and b is equal to zero
i'm just finding the square roots
of nine well you can see there are two
of them one's at three
and one's at negative three we only take
usually when we're in real number land
we just think about the principle square
root
which would be positive 3 but in complex
numbers
negative 3 is just as valid so it's not
the principal square root but it is
one of the square roots nonetheless so
what conclusions can we draw when you're
having a think about square roots of a
complex number please think not just
algebraically not just
arithmetically but also visually there
is this wonderful relationship in terms
of the arguments and the angles
in terms of the symmetry around these
graphs when you wrap your head around
these strange hyperbolas and how they
interact with each other
and you can also see that a lot of the
conclusions that we drew had to connect
together you know for instance
our understanding of complex numbers in
exponential form
and our understanding of complex numbers
in rectangular form
they all interweave very closely
together